let's go next to Dan from Oregon Dan
from Oregon welcome to the David packman
show what is on your mind today
David um
I uh I'm trying to
figure out where I'm at politically
right now uh you know I
was very much a backer of most of the
democratic establishments goals you know
in my younger years and I'm starting to
do more and more research and and
looking at how
uh
difficult it is to really move the
needle on a lot of these big political
issues with the constant Stranglehold of
the
capitalist class and
just wondering where where
conversations could go where uh you
think that we could actually move the
needle in getting people to recognize
the
inherent Hill we're trying to climb uh
over
you know these giant changes that need
to be made when there's the big money
influences just constantly uh keeping
their boot on her this is so tough I
mean I wish there was a simple answer
but you're basically saying how can you
circumvent the system that got us to
where we are
without having any system but that
system with which to do it right and
this is this is what makes this stuff so
difficult you accurately diagnose that
there are so many people that aren't
even sort of like aware of the top level
structural and systemic things that need
to happen you know I think that these
things include campaign Finance how we
run elections media you know I've talked
about like my big overarching issues
that affect every issue but we're sort
of limited by using the very broken
system we have to get people to
recognize this stuff and it is the very
same system which makes it so a lot of
people can't afford to take time off in
order to go to a protest and all these
things so I mean listen I could repeat
like the same stuff I always say but
obviously it's not working in any real
way so I don't have an answer and it's
sort of like one of the most critical
questions which is great we've
identified the problems of the system
and now we need to work within that
system in some way like I know you can
say we'll work outside the system right
but so how are we going to communicate
with people we've got social media
traditional media print media you can go
out and do street preaching but we know
kind of how that works so it is a really
difficult question and I wish I had a
better answer
I I realized it was a very broad
question but
um you know I I really
value the way you uh put things out
there uh and I just wanted to hear your
take on that but it's something that I'm
very interested in uh putting some
energy into and learning more about and
uh yeah just uh
I would love to see
some movement in that direction as far
as getting more people on board it's
like crazy to me that I sit and talk to
people that you know
uh consider themselves being on the
right yeah when I
kind of talk about the goals of what you
know we're trying to socialism
essentially would would accomplish
without actually saying socialism they
tend to jump on board real quick and
agree with me but that's interesting
well as you know Dan I am not a
socialist but I still share many of the
same immediate next steps that you would
identify I'm sure
yeah right well we all know that
corporate strangleholders is uh killing
us all all right my friend thank you for
bringing up this important issue I
appreciate it have a good day all right
there goes Dan from Oregon let's welcome
back to the program Johnny from Boston
Johnny welcome you're going to be
watching CPAC at all
oh boy
no you're not watching it okay fair all
right good I have other things to watch
that's fair I totally respect that
um so I wanted to ask about your uh
interview with Pandora box I know it
wasn't on the show but I saw it kind of
on the link I actually suggested to
watch Pandora how did you get connected
with her and how has the response been
so um well my colleague John uh handled
making the initial contact and
um actually Pandora was connected to the
show the dish that I had a cameo on and
so I actually think that was the
connection and the response has been
pretty good I have to tell you I mean
listen the homophobes and the anti-drag
and the anti-trans and everybody in that
space came up with their same
predictable responses but a ton of
people wrote to me saying I learned a
ton about the difference between drag
performers and trans people which I I I
was actually kind of shocked that a lot
of people didn't realize we're talking
about two different things and just
generally people were very positive
about the interview
that's good I loved it I was I was so
excited I actually recorded a podcast
with her drag sister Aggie Dune from
Rochester
um and I was like do you know what she
did she's doing some great she's doing
God's work right now
um and especially with have you heard
about the thing going on in Tennessee
with the governor yeah we covered it
earlier this week where he's doing all
this anti-drag stuff and then he was
confronted with a picture of himself in
Drag
yeah and it's it's like it's crazy
because Nashville has some amazing drag
performers it's like I I'm really
worried that it's going to put a lot of
them out of work because the bill is
really Draconian it's all crazy I mean
like listen what I really learned from
the interview uh with with Pandora was
there's really nothing to be worried
about in this entire drag Panic that
there is
yeah as if I didn't already know that
but you know
sure I mean there's nothing to work
there's nothing to worry about there
really is exactly and
you know I I one of one of your other
colleagues earlier talked about uh
George Santos and how you talk about I I
call her Katara Rivage because you know
I I'm a part-time drag queen so I have
no problem calling her by her drag name
okay I understand why you didn't want to
but just letting you know I would I
would call her Katara and I will
continue to call her guitar all right
Johnny you do you my friend I appreciate
that all right thanks David appreciate
it all right there is Johnny from Boston
always great to hear from him
imagine for a second that you try
logging into your email account only to
find that your password was changed an
hour ago and then you get notifications
of activity from your bank and then your
credit cards that is what identity theft
is like and it's a horrible feeling and
we dealt with it at the show not that
long ago but now I have an app called
Aura which gives me much more peace of
mind our sponsor Aura is the all-in-one
solution for keeping your online account
safe because Aura will scan the dark web
for your personal info passwords social
security number and you get fast alerts
when they find something you also get
fast alerts about credit inquiries Aura
protects all of your devices from
malware or even requests the removal of
your info from data broker sites and
Aura helps you manage what your kids can
do on their devices you can restrict
certain apps set screen time limits set
Focus times when you need them off of
devices go to aura.com Pacman to try it
free for seven days your login
credentials might already be floating
around out there and Aura will tell you
instantly for free the link is down
below